it's just a job sir some old block
[Music]
payment smug
bastard
[Music]
oy
[Applause]
[Music]
bloody hell where did you come
from well I was born in Crawley but
that's by the by who are you working for
I never got his name old chap big
mustache or some kind of uniform who's
ours maybe what's his game please you'll
kill me and a three-story drop Will
shatter your legs and send you to the
workhouse difference is you can run from
him tomorrow my lives are going to
attack the prime minister's Carriage on
the way to
Parliament perfect
h
what's the meaning of this who the devil
are you prime minister I'm your new
bodyguard Jacob fry I wasn't informed of
any new bodyguard who's your commanding
officer let the voicey speak
DIY Madam apologies but we've learned of
a threat on your life and the Met
thought it best to move quickly threat
what sort of threat
that sort if you excuse me a
moment where' they come
[Music]
from
making
[Music]
pain on your
mate
near
[Music]
I've got
a get you
down
out you have my help
[Music]
see here what's all this not so fast
your
[Music]
Excellency
steady
on who's a good horse you
are
steady
on help you come
[Music]
on that's the
way everyone all
right we seem to have come through
unced you
Mr
f it was gladon I bet my life on it this
is perfectly and cheaping with this
distinct lack of
character Show Yourself Glon show
yourself you fous mck
snip and he's hardly going to be in the
B with a G is
[Applause]
he damn gladston that bloody man he will
pay for
this thank
[Music]
you